all right um speaking of women leading
the way turning now to a book that aims
to be the talk of family dinner tables
across the country Heather McGee is the
board chair for color of change a racial
Justice organization in her best-selling
book she shares ideas on how we can
tackle racism together she says
Prejudice extends from the loss of
public school pools excuse me to the
lesser-known beginnings of the subprime
mortgage crisis for some of us which
looks to looks at how racism affects all
Americans has been adapted for younger
readers Heather how you doing this
morning I'm so great thanks for having
me so why did you want to adapt this
book for younger readers you know
today's middle and high school students
are already part of the America that's
becoming right where there's no dominant
racial majority they're the most diverse
generation in American history and yet
the debate they hear about race and
racism from adults and politicians is so
often US versus them and the sum of us
has a message that says you know what we
can all Prosper together racism hurts
everyone and we all have a stake in
defeating it in our time you said it's a
better world when we all Prosper
together and there are so many
um myths and so many stereotypes that
people really don't understand I like
what you said that when you think about
segregation you said whites are more
segregated than blacks when you think
about diversity in schools it's actually
better when you're when you are being
educated in a diverse school could you
give some examples of that that's right
and apparently white Americans 75
percent of them have reported having uh
entirely white social networks right
white Americans are most likely to live
on their own not with anyone who doesn't
look like them or have their background
in the book I talked to a young student
named Fiona whose parents decided when
she was young not to sort of send her to
the quote-unquote good school that was
almost entirely white away from her more
integrated neighborhood and she went to
the local public school and she says
that meant everything to her a white
young student who says you know what I
learned empathy I learned how to create
authentic relationships with people who
were different from me she says I feel
like diversity is completely normal and
I want to be that way my whole life this
is how it's supposed to be yeah yeah you
know Heather I quote you constantly when
your first book came out you know you
always hear me say history shows up in
your wallet yes
that's Heather yeah that's Heather
that's Heather's line he does he does
say that say that all the time it is the
perfect reaction to somebody I thought
it was your line though all right that's
all right that's what an author wants
just go out there and have the ideas but
I I am curious you grew up in a black
neighborhood in Chicago right but you
went to a boarding school that was
mostly white nearly all white yeah so
how did that background influence your
work so I grew up in the south side of
Chicago 90 plus percent black and you
know it was wonderful it was a thick
black middle class neighborhood and then
when I went to middle school I went to a
mostly white boarding schools white
mostly a white and Asian and it really
helped me at a young age realize the
stereotypes that I've received were
false and that Underneath It All We are
all human we all sort of want the same
things we all dream the same dreams and
it helped me become curious about well
where did these stereotypes come from
where did these stories come from who's
selling us these stories how are they
profiting from these racist stories and
that's really set me on my path to
ultimately writing to some of us you
know I love the chapter no one fights
along and you start with the story very
descriptive about the Nissan workers
forming that Union but it's a prime
example of how we need to do this
together that's right this country has
been divided recently more than it's
ever been what is your advice to the
younger generation who you're aiming to
touch with this book about working
together you know that is really the
core message of the book is that the
most important things in life we simply
can't do on our own we can recycle all
we want we can't address global climate
change on our own the biggest challenges
take Collective action and in a
multiracial society that takes
multi-racial Collective action so young
people need to realize that they can
reject the zero-sum US versus them
thinking that they get which means what
when you say yeah that basically
progress for one group has to come at
the expense of right that we can't have
mutual progress that is a core story
that says fear our growing diversity
fear black history because it's counter
to American history right no it's all of
our shared history and when we
understand it and we understand how an
elite has always used racist ideas to
divide us then we can unlock our
Collective power and I call that
solidarity dividends these gains that we
can have through cross-racial solidarity
one of my favorite lines in the book let
diversity be the superpower that's right
right that's so true Heather McGee thank
you so much we appreciate it how racism
hurts everyone is on sale now